uh I just saw did in Paris just have a
new certification yeah it just went
diamond yeah crazy and it's crazy
because you know that was like a few
years before the streaming there so that
was like people really buying that song
that's that's like the difference in the
game now like I just feel like
it was like a little more earned back in
the day like I just seen ice spice how
long she's been out less than here she
got a billion streets like I'm like I
spiced it I gave us in a wild place I'll
be like I think she's out streaming like
almost everybody except like Bad Bunny
and Drake maybe that's that's incredible
you know whatever she did in her life to
get that blessing for sure but you know
just music Wise It's like wow this is
the era we in you know you gotta accept
it I guess I remember at your old house
in your studio you had like um you had
the Grammy and then you had there was
like a Michael Jordan photo or something
and then there was like um the canvas of
like when Jay and Kanye I think they
were doing in Paris I think it was that
that was that was right there it was a
parent it was a picture in Paris yeah
um it's crazy to think like how much
that record like kind of changes your
trajectory of like just hit boy like I
remember during that time there was like
you were you were like one of the young
producers around a good music My Guy
lifted from Phoenix and did mercy and I
remember he was just telling me all
these stories about like being in hotel
rooms like back to back to back with
like yourself everybody everybody
everybody
what's like one of the craziest like uh
stories you could tell about like just
those days like working with gay working
with the good guys it's a lot man
definitely like that uh trip I'm sure
lifted is talking about we had all went
to London one time and everybody was
there Sean push it two chains you know
obviously yay just being locked in I
remember it was so crowded in uh one of
the hotel rooms and everybody came in
because they was working on it was
either click or Mercy one of the two and
like Sean was sitting on the floor with
a mic like this like recording a hook
for one of them joints and I just I'll
never forget that Craig a was right here
change was in everybody was in there
just a room full of people and they just
was getting it done by any means like
right there
um obviously you and Kanye kind had I
would I wouldn't say a falling out but
definitely not the greatest times in
terms of your guys's relationship how is
it is it is there any relationship at
all these days
um I mean
I haven't uh talked to him since we I
did the easy join with game like but I
ain't got no issues with you my uh I
heard that because I just worked on I
don't want to say who project well I
worked on somebody project I heard they
played him a song like this is just a
few days ago somebody texted me like yo
bro play yeah your song and it was like
yo we need Hit Boy to pull up so I don't
know you know he's I hey I heard he's
cooking right now yeah I heard that too
I heard he is in the studio I heard so
I'm with him man for sure yeah I ain't
got no issues with yeah anybody I know
Freddie's working with him right now
there's a lot of them I've seen I heard
about that yeah a lot of Kanye he's got
shoulder pads you know what I'm saying
yeah ain't no ain't no shoes no shoes he
wearing the socks it's kind of crazy man
if anybody I don't even question it
though boy because I remember when the
early gay [__] the the clothing I was
like No One's Gonna wear this look man
we might all be in shoulder pads in like
six months you know that's funny I don't
know if I can take it there but I feel
uh would you and Benny do it sequel to
the album that you guys did together we
uh he announced that me and out is doing
his album together like I got you know
all we've done probably like 15 16 new
songs I don't know how many he goes is
that the Def Jam debut yeah okay yeah I
don't know how many he gonna pick out
the batch but he got some joints for
Alchemists some joints with me I know we
got a couple other producers in the mix
too but predominantly it's supposed to
be me and Alchemist and that's supposed
to come August 11th or 12th something
like that it's crazy you know who I want
to see you work more with because I feel
like
some of the best records that were on
his best album from King to a goddess
Conway and you had your you that was
during that kind of same era that you
were working with Benny I remember being
in some of those sessions
um what's up would you would you uh work
with Conway again of course yeah nice
for sure I'll be I mean I'll be down to
work with whoever want to lock in with
me everybody be in their own pocket they
own Zone but when I cross paths I'm
gonna definitely I can give whoever some
[__] you know that's how I feel you know
pops I'm curious when you're
incarcerated you know your son's out
here doing this [__] thing where you
at do you remember where you were at
when you find out you won a Grammy for
album of the Year hip-hop out of the
year because he had already had you know
Grant a grant you know but I'm saying
like I feel like this one was different
oh [__] no I didn't even know
um for real it was probably in the hall
at that time
yeah uh yeah I was I think I didn't have
a phone at the time I wasn't tapped in
right yeah I was in yeah I was in the
hole yeah it was a little spurt I was in
the hole
but yeah when I found me I knew it was
going to run it up though yeah
like when you're in the did you get
Wi-Fi service in there like does the
signal come in well it does yeah but you
don't get like are you able to stream
like songs and [__] well if you gotta if
she's active yeah the account is active
right yeah yeah so you're able to like
listening
oh fire and he was sending me like
samples and [__] from The Joint like yo
cut this up oh [__] it was just still
being creative the best we could that's
fire when is your official solo album
coming or is that not are we doing the
duo thing nice solo coming that's the
next thing you dropping yeah we
mastering right now oh so it's finished
oh yeah the first one it's like like I
said it's like 100 some songs we're
gonna drop albums on albums more Duo
[__] solo my solo whatever it is we just
going